I found all kinds of articles [music]
about different celebrities that are
quote using acupuncture. According to
the International Academy of
Acupuncture, this ancient system is
based on the concept that disease
results from disruption in the flow of
key orqi energy.
>> Oh,
>> and imbalance in the forces of yin and
yang, which again is a mystical energy.
>> Key is spiritual demonic.
>> And we're going to we're going to get
there.
>> We'll get there. The Matrix and
acupuncture. Did you guys ever think you
were going to put those two together?
>> I didn't remember that there was
acupuncture in the Matrix.
>> We did.
>> Which which one? One, two, or three?
>> One when they Well, I mean, they might
have done it in the other ones, but when
they w when they woke Neo up, they
pulled him out of that that pod thingy
and that was the first thing that they
did was they were putting acupuncture on
him.
He still [music] needs a lot of work.
>> What are you doing?
>> Your muscles have atrophied. We're
rebuilding them.
>> Why am I, sir?
>> You've never used them before.
>> [music]
>> So, lots of movies, Matrix, and you said
something like Steven Seagal.
>> Yep. Yep. He had a movie called Hard to
Kill many years ago. I probably watched
it more than any other Steven Seagal
movie.
>> Right.
>> And uh there's definitely acupuncture in
that.
[music]
>> [music]
>> And you know what's interesting too is
um Hollywood is promoting an infat
uation almost with eastern mystical
healing.
>> So instead of them going to God for
healing or going to the word of God,
they're turning to the far east for
healing. So um yeah, some of the things
we're going to look at in here, we're
going to see people like Oprah and other
very prominent celebrities that are
promoting.
>> Can you explain what is acupuncture?
>> Well, like Dr. Oz said, acupuncture is a
form of Chinese medicine that's been
used for thousands of years in China.
It's it's come to America. It's it's
been here for about 20 some odd years or
so.
>> And people have been using it for 2,000
years to do what?
>> It treats uh any condition from
allergies to obviously pain to
gastrointestinal issues, a wide range of
chronic uh diseases.
>> Okay. Isn't there something too you can
just get it to just to feel like woohoo?
>> Well, yeah. That's [laughter]
>> that's when you want that woohoo
feeling.
>> Absolutely. It's it's also used for
wellness and uh and to to boost your
immune system. So you don't have to
actually be sick to get it.
>> So they go in close to nerves but not in
nerves and they stimulate those nerves
which then send messages back to your
brain and then your brain releases a
chemical called endorphin. That's what
gives you the runner's high and the
endorphins are
>> I'm going to get a runner's high right
here.
>> You're gonna get it right now.
>> And actually that's the mechanism we
think it works and we actually have
proven that.
>> So the first one we're going to do is in
the hand.
>> In the hand. And I'm desensitizing the
point. And
>> did you feel anything?
>> A little.
>> Oh, look. I GOT
[cheering]
[applause]
>> OH, I I I KIND OF GOT THE IDEA.
>> OKAY.
>> I I got the idea. That's what it feels
like.
>> That's what it feels like.
>> It's not bad. It's not bad.
>> I'm not going to get a I'm not going to
get an endorphin rush from two. I know.
>> No. No.
>> But it's not bad.
>> Not bad at all.
>> Not bad at So Eric, I'm curious whe when
people have talked or if I've read about
acupuncture, to be honest with you, I
always thought it was a bit strange. I
was like, how does a needle do anything
for you when it just gets poked into
your body? But what how do people
explain it is the scientific
method behind it and why is it supposed
to work? And why do you say with the
background you have in Chinese medicine
and and martial arts and all those
things, why do you say that's that's
bogus?
>> There is no science behind it. He's
trying Dr. Oz was trying to come up with
there's a nerve and acupuncture is not
based on anything that has to do with
nerves.
>> They even tell you that. I mean the the
Chinese the masters and the doctors that
that do this, it has nothing to do with
nerves. It has nothing to do with nerve
signals at all. Um, we're going to get
into that here here in a second. Let me
uh I want to open. This was something to
me that was interesting because
>> there's all kinds of people. I mean, I
found when I was doing the research, I
found all kinds of articles about
different celebrities that are quote
using acupuncture. Um, you know, Robert
Downey Jr. and I mean like there was
there was a huge list of people that
claimed to do this and they've claimed
to have had positive benefits from it,
>> right? Um, one of the things that we
found was is like I can remember when I
was growing up, yoga, acupuncture,
raiki, all that kind of stuff was more
out there. It was like on the fringe.
Regular doctors wouldn't even talk about
it. But that has changed.
>> Um, I want to show you something that I
found here. This is a complimentary and
alternative medicine market size trends
and statistics analysis. It says,
"According to recent studies from Grand
View Research, the global complimentary
and alternative medicine market was
valued in US dollars at $117
million in 2022."
>> That's alternative healing, right?
>> Meaning that's how much are they
generating?
>> Yes.
>> Wow. That figure is now estimated to
reach 4
or 44
billion by the year 2028.
>> Wow.
>> In three more years, 404 billion.
Alternative. We're not talking about
regular scientific medicine.
They say with one out of every five
people living in the United States alone
currently reporting that they are using
some form of alternative or quote
complimentary medicine on a regular and
ongoing basis.
I'm going to show just a couple of
magazines that that sort of give you an
idea of how popular this is becoming.
Natural health, it actually says raise
your vibration, [snorts] holistic ways
to enhance your energy. And people are
getting used to hearing words like that
like vibration and we're associating
that with science.
>> Yeah. Arurveetic eating and all that.
>> Yeah. Um Time magazine alternative
medicine you know on the front cover.
Time magazine how your mind can heal
your body. [snorts]
Time magazine uh Dr. Andrew Wheel who is
very very well known. Um
>> God has alternative medicine options
that are actually good. You know, like
like for example, herbs. Yes.
>> Like many herbs are actually used to
heal the body. Yes.
>> They're not some new age weird thing or
some like even demonic spiritualistic
thing. They're they're actual like back
in the day they didn't have medicine and
so you had to use things from nature. My
grandmother was that way,
>> right? Uh hydrotherapy, you know, using
water at different temperatures is
scientifically proven to heal the body.
It's technically alternative medicine,
but it's good. And then you can see how
Satan then uses, oh, I'm going to use
this other kind of medicine that is has
a spiritual connection to it and and
present that as an alternative medicine.
But it's it's something completely
different.
>> Satan always blends light and darkness,
good and evil, because that's how he
that's how he gets people. Cuz if it was
all evil, you'd never go near it. He
says, "If I can attach some good to it,
some truth in there, but there's a
little bit of poison and lies mixed in
with it or deception,
>> that's how he gets people."
>> Um, holistic magazine and like I go to
the health food store every single week
to buy things and it's like this this is
what covers the magazine.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, at the cash register, almost
everything that they promote is based in
Eastern healing.
>> Yeah. I mean, the word holistic isn't a
bad word. so to say, right? I mean, it's
like means whole, right?
>> We'll see.
>> Okay,
>> we'll see. I'm just going to glance
through these real quick just to show
what's there. Now, this is interesting.
This is getting a little more down to
the nitty-gritty.
>> Um, this is Georgetown Medicine.
Georgetown University.
>> It's a Jesuit university.
>> Yeah. And they're saying caring for the
whole person, which is like what you're
talking about with something they call
integrative medicine. Mhm.
>> And then the other one I found was very
interesting because they say the art and
science of traditional medicine and
they're showing traditional Chinese
medicine
>> and the yin-yang symbol.
>> That's right. And it's interesting
because the Bible says that the time is
going to come where they are going to
use terms and call it science falsely
so-called.
>> Um it's not science, but that's what
they want to make us believe. I know
Keith when he was involved in the
martial arts like I was um when it came
to like Chinese ki gong or Chinese
healing a lot of the masters would use
scientific terminology in order to give
more credibility to what they were
teaching so that it sort of like um it
took away the fear of this is spiritual
um so they would use that's why the last
grandmaster that I trained under he
liked to use the word energy instead
ofqi we knew what he was talking about
but he would say energy
>> because energy makes people think, oh
yeah, it's electricity, it's whatever.
And the question that I have found is
that we always need to ask people when
they talk about energy in medicine is
say, are you talking about 12 volts? Are
you talking about 110? Are you talking
about 220? What kind of voltage are you
talking about?
>> And when they go, no, no, no, it's not
that kind of energy. You say, oh, you're
talking about like the energy like in
Tai Chi, spiritual energy. It's
spiritual.
>> Got to go watch the terms. Yeah. I
remember my dad had the charts of, you
know, the the different parts of the
body and they would have, you know, like
on the specifically like hands and feet.
They'd have like this section over here,
you know, would be
>> relates to that organ or this one over
here would be an organ, you know, so
they'd have the heart and the lungs and
all all different places. It was always
fascinating.
Acupun not acupuncture, but acupressure
similar.
>> Yes. Yes.
these two magazines. Again, this is sort
of getting to where the it's telling you
what the issue is. Um, traditional
Chinese medical sciences, which is funny
because they're not there's nothing
about traditional Chinese medicine
that's medical. It's not medical, it's
it's spiritual. Um, and then
spirituality and health. And you know,
he's wearing a Buddhist
>> gown.
>> This is what is so deceptive. All
physical healing from the history of the
world, all physical healing has been
known to be spiritual in nature.
All if you go back, if you go back in
the Bible, even if you go back in
history,
>> um in the Bible, when you wanted to be
healed, who did you go to? The priest or
to the prophet?
>> Remember when non the leper, he he
wanted to be healed and none of the
doctors could do anything. And he said,
"I've heard there's a prophet in Israel
that can see me healed."
>> Or Elijah lays on the boy.
>> That's right.
>> I mean, that's a spiritual thing.
>> But even even in
not Christian cultures, the Greek
culture, the meersians, the Babylonians,
they knew that healing is always a
spiritual event.
>> It has to come from quote the gods.
>> Um, they just used the doctor in order
to get it there.
This is just a a basic diagram that
shows the progression of where we've
come. You know, years ago, back in the
70s, it was alternative medicine. And
they've realized alternative, most
medical doctors didn't want anything to
do with that cuz I don't want
alternative. I want the legitimate.
>> And then they came up with the term
holistic, you know, the whole body. And
then it went to complimentary, which
means well, you can do this along with
your [clears throat]
>> right. And now they're calling it
integrative medicine. And even my son
who's about to go into medical school,
he said, he said, "Daddy," he said,
"This is everywhere." He said, "The best
medical schools are also teaching
integrative medicine." And some of that
is good, but some of it is very
spiritualistic, not in a good way.
[snorts]
>> That this is Newsweek magazine, you
know, spiritual living,
>> all the chakras.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I want to just touch on this,
Scotty. Like you said, holistic.
Holistic means the whole body, right?
And we're going to show a couple of
quotes from uh different eastern
healers.
Holistic means mind, body, and spirit.
And that word is used in martial arts.
It's used in yoga. It's used in
traditional Chinese medicine, in
Ayurveda.
What caught me though is okay, I know
what the mind is.
I know what the body is. What are they
talking about when they say spirit? M
>> because [clears throat] the spirit and
the mind like our brain is a physical
it's a physical organ. It's not the
mind. The mind is something that you
can't put your fingers on and you can't
stick it under a magnifying glass.
>> It's your personality. It's your
consciousness.
>> You can't tear that apart and understand
it.
>> So when they say mind, body, and spirit,
the question that always has to come is
what spirit are they talking about? M
and then also like Oprah for example you
pulled up earlier, she's very much into
like she says she's a Christian but then
she's also into all the new age stuff
and this kind of stuff and and talk when
you when she says that she worships
Jesus you have to ask yourself what kind
of a Jesus which Jesus are you
worshiping? You know it's the same thing
here.
>> That's right. You know, like I know um
Oprah has always had a bunch of like
super spiritualistic people on there.
Like does she have like pastors and
stuff on there?
>> Not unless she has like real like unless
they're very emergent,
>> you know, biblical sound people, uh
people like that. She wants people that
>> she's not going to let somebody get on
there unless she's going to humiliate
them that is in opposition to what she's
wanting to teach. She wants people that
are aligned with her personal views and
values.
>> Yeah.
>> And I get that because we would do the
same thing, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Technically, we we do uh everybody does
in their podcast. You don't want to
just, you know, you have a a message you
want to share. So, I'm sure she
>> is in that field as well.
>> Yes.
>> But when you look at what that message
is that she's promoting through all of
the different almost all of the
different speakers, the message is
antichrist. The message is against
Christ. It's against the Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> Deepo Chopra. Everybody just about in
the world knows who Deepo Chopra is.
>> I don't.
>> Okay. [laughter]
>> Who is he?
>> Well, he's like a guru to the to the
celebrities.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah. And he's very very wealthy. Um
>> uh he's also very Hindu.
>> Okay.
>> He runs a healing uh I don't know what
you would call it. Wouldn't call it a
ministry, but he runs a healing center.
>> Gotcha.
>> Um heavily promotes yoga. heavily
promotes arurveda. Listen to what he
says. The word holistic has come to
refer to everything from organic food
and massage therapy to herbal
supplements and eastern healing
practices. All of which are undeniably
valuable and evidence of a growing
consciousness that earlier generations
only dreamed of. The Chopra Center
defines holistic in its original sense
as related to wholeness. Wholeness is
the union of mind, body, and spirit.
>> So that's I mean that's out of his
mouth. He says this is the original
definition. That's the question. What
spirit is he talking about? The union of
mind, body, and and spirit. Mhm.
>> Now, I'm just going to touch on
traditional Chinese medicine before we
get into acupuncture. These are some of
the basics uh within traditional Chinese
medicine. Keyong is is probably number
one even though it's less known. Um it
means energy work or chiong
energy work.
>> Energy work can be done through a lot of
different ways. Acupuncture is probably
the most well-known traditional Chinese
medical treatment. U Moxy Bustion, which
we just saw with that video clip from
Steven Seagal. Herbal formulas, which I
I love herbs. I use herbs. Um the
difference is though is the Chinese
attribute spiritual power to an herb.
They look at every herb and they say,
"Either this is a yin herb or it's a
yang herb. It either promotes heat or it
promotes moisture and coolness." and
they attribute
this this mystical energy to the actual
herb
>> which doesn't exist. Yes, the herb may
be a more drying herb or a more
moisturizing herb, but that has nothing
to do with energy,
>> right?
>> It just has to do with its chemical
nature and its reaction within the body.
Um, they also use meditation,
acupressure
since uh what Keith said and then
cupping. I don't know if you've ever
seen the cupping or not, but a lot of
Hollywood stars are using that where
they take these hot cups and they put
that over top of their skin and it
leaves
>> bad bad marks on on people, right?
>> But everybody says, "Oh, yeah, but it
works. It's got to be good."
>> What exactly is that supposed to be
doing?
>> Moving circulation, um, helping to to
stimulate circulation in the body to
remove blockages.
>> Yeah. which I'm like getting in a sauna
also is good for your circulation.
That's true. Exercising is good for your
circulation. Hydrotherapy.
>> Yeah. So, acupuncture is it
[clears throat] science or sorcery? And
this for me this was intriguing because
I was always, even though I never did
acupuncture. I never had it, you know,
treatment with it. I was always
intrigued by it because, you know, as
Keith knows, the higher you get in
martial arts, everything becomes about
energy, about chi,
>> about chi, right? Yeah. And acupuncture
is all about chi.
>> Mhm.
>> So for me it was like that was something
I began reading about because I was like
okay I'm practicing Chinese keyong and
shaolin kung fu and these other things
iikido that deal with this energy. How
is this energy manifest in healing
through acupuncture?
I'm going to show you just sort of some
of the background.
The oldest reference to acupuncture is
found in a book that they claim is 5,000
years old called the Yellow Emperor's
Classic. This book was was originally an
account of the discussions between the
legendary Yellow Emperor and his priest
concerning the cause and treatment of
disease. So he went to the priest to
find out how do we treat disease.
All of the diagnosis and remedial cures
are based solely upon the five element
theory and the believed flow of mystical
yin and yang energies within the body.
>> Five elements is similar to like the
five elements of witchcraft.
>> Wow.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> And we're going to get into that here in
a second.
>> Water, fire, spirit, and air.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And with the Chinese, um, you
don't have spirit and air. That's the
same thing. They have metal, which also
can symbolize. So you have earth, fire,
water, wood, and metal.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> But it's the same thing. You can call it
different names, but it's the same
thing.
>> And are you going to go into like what
it actually means? Okay. I'm really
curious about this. Now,
>> it's interesting because there's five
elements.
>> This is a Japanese pigota. Um,
they're used to channel energy or to
invite spiritual energies into a temple
or into a training hall or into a yard
or a person's house.
>> And they have five layers.
>> Y
>> you also have the five element theory.
This is the five element theory within
Chinese medicine.
>> So you've got the wood, the fire, the
earth, the metal, and the water. And
this is the mystical way that they
explain how each of these elements
connect with each other.
>> Um, and I saw something I don't know if
I if I put it in here. I saw something
this past week that was intriguing to
me. There was actually um and if I
remember correctly, it was a uh a
celebrity that was talking about this
energy and they said,
"We do not actually exist. We do not
actually have a mind that's us that we
identify. They said we are actually made
up of five elements that are constantly
interchanging with each other.
>> Interesting.
>> It was very I know it's like red flags.
>> The there's a yin-yang at the front top
right. Can you explain a little bit
about that? Because my understanding is
that it's like a they they they see that
they need to have a perfect balance
between darkness and light. Right.
>> Whereas Jesus says there is no light
darkness in him at all. He's all light.
That's what he wants. We don't want to
have sin and and righteousness. We want
just righteousness. Yeah. But what
there's a little bit of a text
underneath it. Is is the are these five
elements divided up under the ying and
the yang? Is that what it says?
>> No. This is actually talking about
different examples of the yin and yang.
>> Oh, okay. Okay.
>> And we're going to we're going to go
into that here.
>> So, for example, like the one on the
left under yin, it says negative. The
one on the right under yang, it says
positive.
>> Gotcha. Hot and cold, male and female,
heaven and earth, light and dark. Yeah.
>> Water versus fire.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, this is this is interesting because
you have five powers, five elements,
elementals.
And you said something else. You said,
is that the same five that is in
>> the witchcraft?
>> What symbol do you see used in
witchcraft above every other? pentagram
>> which is five points.
>> Mhm.
>> Mhm. And they use that too with the five
elements.
>> Yes. Yep.
>> A lot of times though that it's a little
bit fluid
>> in spiritualism because that the fifth
one spirit
>> will often times be split in two.
>> Mhm.
>> And so you'll have then six.
>> So yeah. And that's it's kind of a a
fascinating thing the way that the way
that is kind of like seen in pop
culture. Uh you take the movie Frozen 2,
for example, when Elsa goes to her
sister and she's explaining that
everything is good now. They all won,
you know, and and her sister realizes
that she's um the fifth element.
Uh Elsa's response to her is she's like,
"Well, mother had two daughters." And as
they're standing there, they are they're
represented in color as white and black.
>> You are the fifth spirit. You are
[music] the bridge. Well, actually, a
bridge has two sides and mother had two
daughters.
>> So,
>> ying and yang.
>> Yeah, the yin and yang. So, it it often
times is split that the the fifth one is
split. M
>> and it interesting that Bruce Willis
played in a movie called The Fifth
Element.
>> Mhm.
>> years and years ago.
>> There's also that animation by Disney,
Elementor, Pixar, I think. Yeah.
>> Oh, Elemental.
>> Elemental. That's what it is.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's it's rampant. It's
like
>> Voltron when you were growing up. There
five robots that made up a bigger robot
and they were all different colors. It
was the um some of the I think the
original Power Rangers there was five
and there was you go on their wiki
there's different associations to the
different elements to them and
>> so all of that
>> is rampant Captain Planet Avatar same
thing
>> all of that has been done for a purpose.
>> Yeah.
>> Avatar meaning the the anime not the
movie.
>> I want to show you something that was
really intriguing to me. This is
something I found online called the
electric universe. And it's talking
about gods and planets.
What did every pagan religion in the
entire world worship?
>> Stars.
>> Stars. Planets.
>> Suns. The things out there.
>> When you read some of the occult
writings and like Blovatki and Alice
Bailey and other people,
>> they actually talk about the fact that
the pagans knew were not worshiping the
planet. the planet or the sun or the
moon is just a physical symbol of a
[clears throat] spiritual entity that we
can't see.
>> So that's what it's just like the Buddha
idol. They they're not really bowing to
the Buddha. That symbol is just there to
symbolize something spiritual that can't
be seen.
>> Yeah.
>> Now this is what's interesting. You have
the sun and the moon and then how many
planets after that?
>> One 2 3 four five.
>> That's the five elements. M
>> and I'll show you in a stronger way here
in a minute.
>> Mars is the god of what? War.
>> War. Yeah.
>> Mercury was speed and I think sometimes
he was associated with healing. Jupiter,
Venus, Saturn. Those are the five major
gods that every pagan culture has
worshiped.
>> And Venus was reproduction, right?
>> Yes. And sensuality and all kinds of bad
stuff. Now here this is showing the
Chinese version of those five powers.
Ah,
>> in Chinese healing, you've got wood,
fire, earth, metal, and water. In kung
fu, you had the five animal system. The
leopard, the tiger, the serpent, the
dragon, the white crane.
>> In fenue, you had east and south and
center and west and north.
>> In traditional Chinese medicine, you had
the five organ systems, which were
liver, heart, spleen, pancreas, lungs,
and kidneys. And in astrology, you had
Jupiter, Mars, Saturn, Venus, and
Mercury. Whether that be in the Roman or
whether it be Greek, they just had
different names.
>> The devil has had the same, it's the
same thing. He just repackages it for
each culture,
>> right?
>> But it's the same power.
>> Right
>> now, I want to talk about the other the
meridian uh theory. Um and it is a
theory. Now today traditional Chinese
practitioners and acupuncturists will
tell us there's 365 acupuncture points
and they say that they are specific
places on the body where this meridian
which is these elusive mystical pathways
almost like tubes if you could call it
where this energy called chi or keyi or
prana is said to flow through the body.
And what they say is is that when that
energy is blocked,
that's when disease happens.
>> This but this is not what you hear when
you just go to see like I I did physical
therapy like I don't know a year and a
half ago and they offered do you want
acupuncture and I didn't remember why I
didn't understand it but I thought Eric
said it's wrong and I trust Eric because
you are a high up disciple martial arts
and you've studied this. I said no thank
you but they don't tell you this. They
don't tell you this.
>> Well, no. The devil never tells you
right off the bat.
>> But they probably don't even know
themselves. Like this kind of
>> Some of them don't, but the ones that
that are high up do,
>> right? But that high up.
>> It's like the first level Mason, he
doesn't know very much.
>> You know, 33rd degree, you know who
you're worshiping.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, but the meridians, they say that
there are 12 of these, and I'm using the
word tubes, but they're pathways that
this energy flows through throughout the
body.
>> There's 12. Now, think about that.
There's 12.
They say there's 365
acupuncture points on the body. There's
12 meridians, 365 points. There's 12
months in the year. There's 365 days in
the year.
>> When you go back and look at the
original Chinese writing, they only had
360 points, not 365.
>> So there's five added.
>> There was five days added after the
flood.
>> Oh, right.
>> Before the flood, we had a 360.
>> That's true. And that's biblical. It's
in the Bible.
>> It is. Yeah.
>> Um they knew when the change happened.
It's also interesting because the highle
keyong masters and the acupuncturist
they know that in order to correctly do
acupuncture you have to know a person's
birth date.
>> Mhm.
>> And when you put the needles in affects
the results like what day, what time of
the month, what time of the year.
>> It's based on astrology. M
>> um it's not just did I put the needle in
that point and it's going to get it's
going to get neater here in a second. I
shouldn't say neat. These ancient works
that we looked at, you know, the Yellow
Emperor's uh classic and then also there
was some other works that are old, 2,000
years old, 1,800 year old. They reveal
that the practice of insertion of the
needles and the opening quote unquote or
clearing of the meridians is a spiritual
act, not a physical one.
>> So if I've got, let's say it's light, if
I've got this energy running through
this invisible pathway in my body, how
does sticking a needle in there block
that?
>> Yeah. Because you're now connecting the
physical with the spiritual, right?
>> Yeah. But they say you're not blocking
it. you're like
>> you have you have something that's
blocking it and the needle is supposed
to help remove the blockage.
>> But the point I'm making is that a
needle is in a physical realm. That
thing is in a spiritual realm. Yes.
>> You can't use a physical thing to enter
the spiritual unless they're both
spiritual.
>> Amen. Amen. M h
>> the ne they say the needles themselves
act as a small antenna to receive the
subtle vibrations and energy of the Dao
or the cosmos.
>> Wow.
>> The needle is an antenna. Now this this
is what they say. Let me show you what
Science Daily said in 2008.
Quote, "Accupuncture works, but it works
equally well with or without needle
penetration."
This conclusion is drawn from a study
involving 215 cancer patients suffering
from nausea during radiotherapy.
Chosen by lot, 109 received traditional
acupuncture with needles penetrating the
skin. The other 106 patients received a
simulated acupuncture instead with a
telescopic blunt placebo needle that
merely touches the skin. So
approximately half got real penetration
with the needle. The other half there
was no penetration through the skin at
all. Look what they found
>> afterward. 95% of the patients in both
groups felt that the acupuncture
treatment had helped relieve nausea and
67% had experienced other positive
effects such as improved sleep, brighter
mood, and less pain.
>> Yeah. So then it's like, well, why is it
still working?
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. And the other thing that's
interesting is their cancer patients.
They didn't discuss whether or not their
cancer went away.
>> The acupuncture made them feel better,
helped them sleep better, less pain.
They didn't say anything about treating
cancer. Yeah. I think
>> one of the
allures for people and and I can say
this because it's it's crossed my mind.
You you feel like you get in a desperate
situation.
>> Yeah.
medically
and nothing's working. Or the
alternative is like a really expensive
invasive surgery.
>> And you're sitting there faced with
these situations of like, well, what do
I do?
>> Yeah.
>> And you know, you think really expensive
invasive surgery, you know, tens of
thousands of dollars
>> with potential side effects.
>> Potential side effects. Don't know if
it's going to go right, you know, all
that. Or there's this other thing that
costs a fraction
supposedly no side effects.
>> Mhm.
>> And is natural.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, you can see the appeal.
>> Yep.
>> And the devil prays on people that are
in a compromise position.
>> Pain
>> and you're hurting and you just like, I
don't see a way out of this situation.
>> Yep.
you're you're especially if you're
you're in that position where you like
I've prayed about it and it doesn't seem
like anything's happening.
So I guess the question would be if you
use this
is that ultimately I mean I understand
like pseudocience stuff right it's a
spiritual thing
>> is this opening a door
>> 100% and I'll show you I'll show you why
I will show you why
Dr. Scott Greenapple, certified
acupuncturist. He's a doctor.
>> He said, "According to the International
Academy of Acupuncture, this ancient
system is based on the concept that
disease results from disruption in the
flow of key orqi energy."
>> Oh.
>> And imbalance in the forces of yin and
yang, which again is a mystical energy.
Traditional Chinese medicine uses
practices such as herbs, meditation,
massage, and acupuncture
to seek to aid healing by restoring the
yin and yang balance and the flow ofqi.
Acupuncture is the stimulation of
specific points on the body by the
insertion of thin metal needles through
the skin. The needles are intended to
remove blockages in the flow ofqi and
restore and maintain health.
The [clears throat] needles are solid
and contain no chemicals, which is what
Oprah Winfrey was being described to by
[clears throat] Dr. Oz
>> as they do in western medicine. These
disposable needles serve only as an
antenna to allow transfer of energy
through a point in the body.
>> Okay. So basically what it's saying is
and from our understanding that key is
spiritual demonic
>> and we're going to we're going to get
there.
>> We we'll get there. But but coming to
that point right then it's saying so you
have a blockage of your demons you know
hanging out with you and so you need to
stick some needles in there so they so
that you give them access to come and
hang out with you and by the way these
needles only serve as an antenna. Now
what is an antenna? It's supposed to
receive something. That's right. Right.
It's supposed to make sure that like
like when you sit there with your radio
for back in the heyday when we actually
used antennas and radios, you're trying
to find it and the the you know the
audio is distorted and it's distorted
and you keep searching and boom, you've
got it. It's it's angled in the right
way and you receive a perfect flow,
>> a signal.
Now what is scary is is that when you
read the writings of most of the
acupunctures and most of the traditional
Chinese medicine healers, do you know
what they say the primary cause is of
the blockage in theqi energy in the
body?
>> What's that?
>> Emotional. They say emotional is the
primary source of blockage.
>> Why do they say that?
>> Because that's what they can treat. M
>> because the evil spirits that are
working through this, it's easy for them
to affect your mind.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's what they use.
>> I think it just seems to be that the
devil loves to work with your emotions.
>> I mean, it's like
>> Hollywood is just an emotional machine
that basically um they're attaching
different thoughts and feelings to those
things.
>> Yes. And it's important to recognize
that it's it's a halftruth.
>> Yes. People
do deal with stuff. Yeah. That has some
emotional baggage and emotion
>> that can that can cause a downcast
spirit and you know affect their
>> their organs or whatever. So it's a
halftruth just like when he says herbs,
meditation, massage, acupuncture. It's
important that you separate each one of
those things out
as items that seek healing
because they're not they can be used in
a couple of different ways. They can be
used this way or they can be used God's
way.
>> Yep.
>> The herbs can the acupuncture can not
the acupuncture but the the herbs
biblical meditation
>> and there is
>> and even massage massage. Yeah. there's
scientific basis for some of those other
things or biblical basis for some of
those other things. So, you got you have
to be careful and discerning so you
don't throw the baby out with the bath
water.
>> That's right.
>> But you also don't want to be
>> um
>> You don't want to swallow everything
that's
>> You don't want to Yeah, it's a good
analogy. You don't want to swallow
everything that's being given to you.
>> And [snorts] like you said, your mental
health can affect your physical body.
Yes.
>> Like you can actually have physical
ailments because of your mental health.
That is scientific
>> and your emotional health. That's right.
That's right. But that's where Satan has
found the easiest way to affect because
if somebody feels better, even if the
cancer is still there, I feel better.
>> Yep.
>> So they keep coming back.
>> Let me show you where this goes.
This is a statement from Dr. Francis V.
Clark. And she wrote in her PhD, and I'm
not even going to read what her PhD was
entitled, but she referred to our
cultures modern fascination with occult
energies. And this is what she said. In
recent years, we have learned much about
releasing energy, raising energy,
transforming energy, directing energy,
and controlling energy. Yet the energy
we are talking about remains undefined.
>> Bingo.
>> That's right. Yeah,
>> it's spiritual. And we're going to I'll
give you more evidence. I don't want I
don't want any of our viewers just to
swallow what I'm saying. I want to show
you the evidence. You can't define it.
That's a that's a big problem.
>> That's not scientific.
>> It's not. It's like the term conversion
therapy. Like, well, what is that? What
does it mean?
>> And it's And it's [clears throat] almost
like they're offering you something that
that is just devoid of God.
>> Yes.
>> I mean, to be honest, right?
>> Yeah. because God is, you know, if you
were to pray and to have God remove
something, um, I mean, there's a lot of
times that that that there's some
unexplained things that that happen that
you can only attribute that to God. And
it's like here, if you just thought it
was just some energy or blocking or
adding or swallowing or changing the
thing, it's like you don't have any
they're not there's
>> all all healing comes from one of two
spiritual powers.
>> All healing,
>> God or Satan,
>> there's only two.
>> Mhm.
>> We're going to show a connection here
because uh traditional Chinese medicine,
acupuncture is Chinese, Raiki is
Japanese.
>> Oh.
>> Um so we're going to look at this for a
second. The founder of Raiki was a man
named Mika Usu Usui. I think I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly. Um, he was a
sensei or a teacher. He was known as the
father of the healing art. He was born
1865, died 1926.
According to the writings of his
disciples, the aim of Usui's teachings
was to provide a method for students to
achieve connection with a quote
universal life force. Oh wow.
>> Or energy that would help them in
self-development. And we're going to
have to do a program on that sometime
here like self-help and Hollywood.
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm going to put some quotes up here
from some of the different holistic
practitioners. Um Martha Derby said,
"Energy healers have faith that human
beings are inherently
good." Yeah.
>> What did Jesus say? Jesus said there's
none good but one. That's God.
>> That's God. Yep.
Then she says that divine forces support
our greatest good if our intention is
aligned with this goodness. That was
kind of vague.
>> Very.
>> The word reiki is made up of two words
ray and keyi. The word ray means
universal life energy, spiritual
consciousness or all knowing.
>> The word key means breath or life force
or vital radiant energy. Is this similar
to chi or keyi?
>> It's the same thing. Key andqi and
prana.
>> It's all the same thing just different
names.
>> And then the spiritual consciousness,
the all knowing. I'm sure this is a
reference to Lucifer, isn't it?
>> Let's see. [laughter]
>> She goes on and says, "When a healer
resonates with her faith in divine love
and her faith in the nonsepparation
between humans and divinity." Wait a
minute. What do you mean the
non-separation of humans and divinity?
>> The humans are divine.
>> She's saying that we all are gods.
>> Oh boy.
>> There is an automatic invitation to
share that vibration with others.
>> Using intention or the power of our will
to create change on the metaphysical
level is an act of faith. She says the
healer is trusting in the healing
potential of the individual, the
goodness of divine love and confidence
in herself.
>> It is a subtle a system of subtle vi and
the word subtle is um it means you can't
put your finger on it. You can't put it
under a microscope. They use that word
subtle energy.
>> It is a system of subtle vibrational
healing energy that has no medical
contraindications.
It is holistic in that it does not
attack disease in any form, but rather
it encourages the individual towards
balance.
>> Have you ever had Reiki done on you or
performed it?
>> No, but I've had I've had ki gong done
on me, which is the same thing. It's
just the Chinese version.
>> Did you actually feel vibrations?
>> Oh, yeah. You feel all kinds of stuff,
don't you, Keith? When somebody's
projecting chi Yeah, you feel it if they
know what they're doing.
>> Man, that's weird. That's That would
creep me out.
>> It's demons.
>> Yeah. Ad break.
>> Here we are. It's the end of the year.
>> We have been so blessed by your
generosity, your prayers, [music] and
your comments.
>> Every year, we aim to finish strong. And
to do that, we need your help.
>> We have just hired a new person [music]
because we want to make some amazing
videos, but there's a cost.
>> In this room, we will soon have a video
LED wall, and we want to utilize that
tool, but there is a cost. We want to
take care of our employees, but there is
[music] a cost.
>> You know, Jesus came to this earth to
give us eternal life, but there was a
cost for that.
>> We want others [music] to experience
eternal life as well. And so, we ask for
your help.
>> Please [music] consider making an end
ofear gift to one of your favorite, if
not your favorite, ministry. [music] And
you can do that at lls.tv/g TV/g
>> by texting Little Light at 53555
>> or by scanning the QR code on your
screen.
>> I remember I remember the last time the
the last Grandmaster I trained under,
I'd been with him almost nine years. He
came to the school that day and he would
he normally when he wanted to show
energy he would do it by pushing
somebody like you see in Star Wars
without touching them.
>> Mhm.
>> You know even with as long as I'd been
doing it because at that time I'd been
doing it almost what 24 years. It was my
24th year.
>> I I I had trained on how to ground and
how to grow roots and to be immovable.
So he told me, he said, "Eric, I want
you to plant and that means send your
energy down into the ground." So I
planted and I didn't want to, but it was
like it it just came from all those
years of doing it. You know, I felt this
energy going down. I thought it was me
and I grounded and he would take his
hand and he would project energy out of
his hand from 15 ft away and push me off
my feet. I couldn't resist him.
>> Even after 24 years of being in the
martial arts,
>> that's nuts. He would just hold his hand
up and you would feel it. And what it
felt like for me, and it doesn't always
feel the same for everybody, but it was
like if you take two magnets and you put
their polarity towards each other and
you can't make them touch, that's what
it felt like. You physically felt the
push.
>> Wow.
>> Um and you couldn't resist it.
>> That's nuts. It was interesting though
because the last time he came to, you
know, my school,
I was the Lord was delivering me and I
didn't want anything to do with that
energy because I had recognized God had
opened my eyes to realize what this was.
And so I prayed with a couple of my
friends that were students that were
there that I knew believed in Jesus. I
prayed with them that day and I said,
>> "Lord, I don't know. I'm still trying to
figure out what's right and what's
wrong, what's black and what's white." I
said, "So we're just asking you. We do
not want any power to have influence
here that if it's not of you.
>> He came and he tried to do energy that
day and nothing he did worked. None of
it. And he couldn't understand why.
>> I mean, he literally walked to the back
of my school shaking his head after the
last time he tried. He couldn't figure
out why it wouldn't work.
>> Because Satan has to submit to God.
That's right.
>> It's crazy how many how many Hollywood
movies use these kind of concepts and
probably the average person is not aware
of that, you know,
>> and you know, you know why they do that?
Because Satan is wanting to to make the
West familiar with spiritual power. And
he wants to make you think, well, this
is not good. It's not bad. It just is.
>> Star Wars, you had the Jedi that used
the Force. What did the Sith use?
>> The Force. They use the same power.
>> That's what Satan is wanting people to
do. He wants people to say, "There's
this energy and it's not good. is not
evil. It's what you want to do with it.
>> Yeah. Like white magic, black magic,
>> right?
>> Exactly. Good point.
>> Pamela Miles goes on and says, "Reiki
operates on the premise that the subtle
vibrational blueprint is the foundation
of everything that happens on the
mental, emotional, physical, and
spiritual levels. Even the subtlest
shift on the vibrational level, she
says, carries the potential to affect
every level of our experience." M
>> so what this does is when a when a
person goes for a raiki healing and and
they're being told things like this they
become very dependent then either on the
raiki healer on the Chinese you know
healer on the aroma therapy on the
essential oils cuz they're looking for
they're looking inward constantly
>> can I tell a change with that I take
this herb could I feel the difference
and in martial arts for me it was all
about what do you feel do you feel that
and you always are looking inward
instead of looking upward.
>> As a Christian, we're not supposed to
base our life on what how we feel. We're
supposed to base our life on what does
God say.
>> Amen.
>> She goes on and says, "Reiki is not
directed by the practitioner and in this
way it is very different from other
vibrational or bioenergetic modalities
such as therapeutic touch and keyong.
Those treatments are more similar to
medical interventions in that
practitioners evaluate the patient and
they devise a treatment plan. Reiki
needs no diagnosis
because the flow of this subtle healing
vibration is spontaneous and is drawn by
the recipient.
>> When you go in there and you lay down,
>> you are literally saying, "I surrender.
I'm opening myself up for whatever power
is willing to help me."
That's what she's talking about.
>> The practitioner simply places her hands
on the recipient for the firstderee
treatment. That means level one.
>> Or they make the connection for distance
healing at second degree. That means I
can be in my house and I can
>> meditate. I can go into a keyong. I can
channel this energy to go to somebody
else's house a 100 miles away and fix
them without them. I don't even have to
put my hands on them anymore.
>> Right.
>> You think about how like attractive this
is to the to the community that is
suffering with medical conditions and
they don't have to go to the hospital.
Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you know what's weird? The last year,
maybe the last year and a half that I
was in martial arts, I found writing
that this is exactly the same way with
tra with uh traditional acupuncture.
Mhm.
>> After you reach a certain point, um I
think it was in that
>> you don't even need the needles
>> in that book, the the cult of Keon, the
needles are totally irrelevant.
>> You don't even have to be there. You
don't even have to be in the room.
Somebody the higher level they get, they
can be 3,000 miles away and they will it
to happen and the person sees the
results.
>> But it's the same as like voodoo or a
doll or whatever. I mean their pens in
something to happen.
>> That's exa That is exactly right.
>> Wow. Voodoo is acupuncture and it's just
in its most raw form.
>> Interesting.
>> You get a doll and you tell the spirit
world this doll represents that person.
The good thing is is if you are
surrendered to Christ, if you are
consecrated, your life is sold out to
him. They can't touch you.
>> They can't get to you. Yeah. I was
thinking about the exact same thing,
Keith. And it's uh you know, most people
probably wouldn't have have nothing to
do with a voodoo doll, but they are open
to these things because it's so much
more accepted in Western society.
>> And like that doctor with Oprah said, he
talked about nerve. There is nothing to
do with the nerves. Acupuncture has
nothing to do with the nerves at all.
>> But it I mean it's not just voodoo. I
mean there's all kinds of things that
are like that. I mean it's spells and
incantations and all that. It's all
designed to happen at a distance no
matter where the person is. You know,
it's designed to create an effect upon
that other person.
>> That's right.
>> Spiritualism.
>> It's witchcraft.
>> Mhm.
>> So, the question in my mind that came up
is what are what are the they talking
about when they keep mentioning these
frequencies?
Biospiritual energyhealing.com says
there is a subtle bioenergy that flows
through all organic life if it's alive.
Um
it goes by many names and is sometimes
referred to asqi or life force. They say
this energy is expressed as an
electromagnetic vibrational frequency.
And they also connect this with
aromatherapy. They say the pure
essential oils have the highest
frequencies of any measured natural
substance which we're not going to go
into aromatherapy. But I do want to show
you something about this.
>> Well, this is a interesting thing. It's
like essential oils oils can be very
good for you.
>> Yes, they can. But they don't have
spiritual power.
>> Exactly. That's the difference. Like
like you know,
>> I always like the clarity on that one
[laughter]
cuz I like I like lavender. I like those
things.
>> But there's nothing wrong with the plant
or making an oil out of it or smelling
it. And in fact, some of it is very,
like I said, good for you, right? Like
like like um if you have eucalyptus and
your your nose is congested, it opens up
your nose or
>> but It's it's the spiritual components
being added to it.
>> That is a chemical that is a chemical
property.
>> Yeah.
>> But what many people with essential oils
do is and the manufacturers do is they
attach spiritual properties that don't
exist.
>> Dr. Gary Young or DG Gary Young um from
Young Living Essential Oils. This is a
quote from him and he Young Living
Essential Oils is like the top. Doera
has has grown to be an equivalent but
they they were there before anybody
else.
He says, quote, "Clinical research shows
that essential oils have the highest
frequency of any natural substance known
to man, creating an environment in which
disease, bacteria, virus, fungus, etc.
cannot live." Now,
>> okay, hold on. I put essential oils in
my bathroom and I still have mold in my
shower. That does not take it out. One
of the things that really hit me was,
and I'm just going to give you an
example,
>> rose oil from Young Living essential
oils. It's about $300, $280, $300 for a
little bottle of essential oil from
Rose.
>> Um, because it's supposed to have the
highest frequency of all the oils. So,
according to what he's saying, if you've
got the money to go buy a $300 bottle of
oil, you can get yourself to the point
where none of these diseases can exist
in your body. What about the poor
person?
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> And I'm like, Jesus healed people in a
completely different way. It didn't
matter if you were rich or poor.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, listen to what he says. Gary Young
said, "I believe that the chemistry,"
which is true, and the frequency of
essential oils have the ability to help
man maintain the optimal frequency to
the extent that disease cannot exist.
>> Now, let me show you what really threw
me off. This
>> This is shocking. This is rose oil from
Doerra. You can go online and type in
what is the frequency of rose oil and
you will find 50% of the websites that
are legitimate websites will say rose
oil has 320 hertz.
The other 50% of the websites will say
no it has 320 megahertz.
What's the difference between megahertz
and hertz?
>> A thousand.
That's huge. And I when I was looking at
this, I was like, these were legitimate.
>> These were sites that had been there and
people that had been doing this for 50
years.
>> And some of them said 320 hertz, some of
them said 320 hertz. I was like, look,
if this is science, you can't have two
different
>> figures. If this is scientific, there
can only be one figure because you
measure it.
>> Yeah. Debunked.
>> Yeah. It's like it's gone.
>> Yeah.
>> And and Yeah. We're going to do a we're
going to do a video on that soon.
>> Half of them are wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> At best.
>> Yeah. But that that was what was scary.
And then you've got and I know we don't
have time to go into this, but you've
got all these machines that people have
come up with that are called frequency
generating machines that heal. When you
start finding out where all that came
from, like who the source of it was, it
it's terrifying. All of them go back
every I mean hundreds of them around the
world that have developed these things.
They all go back to one source, one man
that developed this idea.
>> That's That's very scary.
>> Well, when you find out where he got it
from, that's Yeah. And we're gonna show
that.
>> But so do you see this an uptick of this
as well with celebrities and pe people
that are like, "Take your take your
essential oils."
>> Well, it's not just the oils. It's the
frequency that we're talking about
because if this food has a certain
frequency and if your body has a certain
frequency and if disease only exists at
a certain frequency,
>> the whole goal then is is to bring that
balance back to the frequencies of your
body. And you can see where that gets
very
>> muddy, very muddy because then it could
be, you know, it's customized for every
person. And
>> this is why you shouldn't eat apples,
Denique, because you know that's right.
Well, I think also people need to be
aware of these things because you'll
hear people say that, "Oh, you use
essential oils. That's demonic."
>> Yeah.
>> And I think that that is also not a true
statement.
>> Yeah. It's not. You know what I mean?
>> I use essential oils. Correct.
>> If I've got a an infection on my hand
from a cut, I use tea tree oil. Then
I'll put lavender on there to help close
the cut up. Or like you were talking
about eucalyptus. I love I'll take a
Q-tip and put eucalyptus in my nose if
my nose is stopped up. You can go to
sleep that way. And it's like it opens
it all up. It has chemical properties
but not spiritual properties.
>> Yeah.
>> Now this is the root. This is where we
start talking about Zen.
>> What we've seen all these people talking
about whether it was acupuncture,
whether it was Reiki, whether it's the
essential oils, they're talking about an
energy that they say is universal. It's
in every living thing, every organic
thing. And this is pantheism. And I'm
going to just show you a couple of
examples from my experience. Um, when I
was in Iikido, one of the men that was
most renowned in the world as an Iikido
instructor, a sensei or a Shihan, I
think he's probably an eighth or ninth
dawn, which is like right under
Grandmaster. He trained under Moria, the
founder of Iikido.
>> He said true power is found in the
spiritual world. And he's talking about
martial arts.
>> Geishin Fukakushi, who was the the
father of modern day karate, he was a
10th dawn. He said, "Spiritual
development is paramount. Technical
skills are merely a means to the end."
>> There you go.
>> Robert James Barat said, "Zen offers an
interesting perspective in the world of
martial arts and spirituality because it
becomes hard to see where the spiritual
philosophy ends and the martial practice
begins. M
>> what does this have to do with what
we're talking about with healing
everything it's the same power
masoyama who was a tenth dawn they
called him the god hand because what he
could do with his hands he said the man
who wants to walk the way or the path of
karate cannot afford to neglect zen and
spiritual training
>> is that also again the same as chi
>> no zen is the Japanese word for what the
Chinese call chan
So you've got Chan Buddhism and you've
got Zen Buddhism. It's the same thing
just one is a Japanese.
>> We're going to get there.
>> Okay.
>> He said always more vital to karate than
techniques or strength is the spiritual
element that lets you move and act with
complete freedom.
>> More than your strength, more than your
techniques, it's something spiritual
that allows you to move with freedom.
Now, how many rings were there in the
Olympics?
>> Five.
Mousashi. He He is probably the most
well-known rider to anybody that's
practiced iikido or iedo or kendo. Um,
the sword training, Japanese sword
training, samurai training. He had a
book he called the book of five rings.
And it's interesting because most of us,
myself included, I thought five rings
was like five, you know, rings.
When you read what he was talking about,
it was five spheres.
>> Mhm.
>> Five spheres. What are the planets?
>> It's a sphere, right?
>> And those are the five gods that
everyone look to for power,
>> right? He said in Zen or Chan Buddhism,
first comes technique practiced so many
times that it is forgotten. Then you
begin to use it. It is when you do not
think about it anymore that you do it so
well. Zen is no more than that. But it
is reaching that state of mind that the
training is all about. You're talking
about possession
>> when you're acting without having to
take conscious thought in order to do
the actions.
>> I see your point.
>> Another master, ancient master lived
from 1571 to 1647. I'm not even going to
try to pronounce his name. Keith, you
you're welcome to try that. If menori um
he said once you have trained yourself
well, your body and limbs will move
automatically without any conscious
effort. Huh?
>> Your mind will not be overwhelmed with
your physical movements. You will employ
techniques unconsciously without having
to think. Once you have achieved this
state, not a single doubt or hesitation
will arise. Train yourself thoroughly
and then forget about it. Throw away
your mind.
They're talking about the what that
other person your your consciousness.
>> Empty your mind.
You will then follow the way without
being aware of it. This is the mystery
of bushidto.
>> Right. And and Jesus says, "Come and let
us reason together."
>> And he also says, "I am the way."
>> Yes. Yeah. But he wants us to use our
mind, our frontal lobe, the frontal part
of the brain where you make the
decisions and do all these things. Uh
the city of your morality, city of your
will. He gave us that. He created us
with that. So to just turn it off and to
have lot something else move where it's
talking about your mind will not be
overwhelmed with your physical movement
that you will automatically move without
any conscious effort. That's like my arm
just lifting up and I'm not trying to do
it.
>> If your hands are moving without you
telling them to that means something
else is moving your hands
>> and what is moving you right
>> now a lot of times I know some of our
viewers may be saying why is he talking
about martial arts? I thought we were
talking about acupuncture. We're talking
about acupuncture and Reiki and this
energy and what the source of those are.
It's Zen. It's Chan.
>> And we're going to show what that is.
>> In Zen or Chan Buddhism, there is a
state of being that is referred to as
Mushin, which is said to be a mental
state in which a very highly trained
martial artist said to enter during
combat. They also practice this mental
state during everyday activities. The
term is shortened from mushian noshin, a
Zen expression which means mind of no
mind and is also referred to as the
state of nomindedness.
That is a mind not fixed or occupied by
thought or emotion and thus open to
everything.
>> What what was the guy that played in um
oh what was the movie? Uh he's he's he's
out there now. Um he played the Grinch.
He played Carrie.
>> Jim Carrey. Have y'all seen like some of
the things he said over the last 5
years?
>> He's lost his mind.
>> Well, he's actually said, "I have now
realized that I don't exist."
>> Yeah.
>> What?
>> Yeah. And you know what happened? He
entered into a character. I think he was
playing the the in that movie Taxi. What
was the guy's name?
>> Andy. Andy Kaufman.
>> Yeah, that's it.
>> He said when he was preparing to play
that part, he tried to become Method
Act. Andy Kaufman and he said afterwards
he said I started realizing who said
that I am Jim Carrey.
>> Maybe I'm known.
>> I don't exist. So uh they're all
characters that I played including Jim
Carrey. Jim Carrey is a great character
and I was lucky to get the part.
[laughter]
But I don't think of that as me anymore.
>> You don't at all. Not really. No. I used
to be a guy who was experiencing the
world and now I feel like the world and
the universe experiencing a god.
>> Maybe I'm I am one with the universe.
>> Yeah, that method acting is very
dangerous and and it really is when you
look into it, it's a form of demonic
possession of letting the spirits work
through you to act the role. And then
some of them don't even get out of it. I
think Andy Kaufman was like that on the
set, right? That he just
>> they were like, "Hey, will
>> will Jim Carrey come on to the set?" And
then they're like the Grinch.
>> Yeah. And they had to
>> Yeah. He said no. And he's not here.
Andy's here.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> That's a demon.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And same with Heath Ledger when he
did uh um back Dark Knight when he
played the Joker. He wasn't getting out
of his role.
>> Yeah.
>> And look what happened. The role wasn't
coming out.
>> A lot of actors that that get fully
immersed in that. Nowhere in the Bible
do you ever see that God is like, uh,
let me take over your mind that you are
not doing anything and and I'm doing
everything.
>> That's right.
>> You know what I mean? It's like God is
God is wanting to reflect his character
in his creation that it's a part of
that.
>> Yeah. That you are you are still acting
as though God would, but not just like
Yeah,
>> that's right.
Encyclopedia Bratannica. This is the
definition of Zen or Chan Buddhism. They
say it is a religious sect derived from
the Hindu word dana which means a
process of meditation used to achieve an
awakening to the Buddha nature.
>> Right?
>> That's Zen. That's what this is all
about. The purpose of Chan or Zen
Buddhism is literally said to be
liberation or enlightenment. Where's the
first place in the Bible that we see
enlightenment talked about? Genesis
chapter 3. Your eyes will be open.
>> Yeah. The [clears throat] gnostics as
gods.
>> Same thing innosticism. You you're
seeking enlightenment. This is all
satanic.
>> The term chan or zen originates from the
Hindu word dana which literally means
meditation. This is a form of meditation
that is described as a lucid awareness
and said to be achieved through focusing
on a single object for a prolonged
period of time. And we did that in the
martial arts.
>> They do that when they put people into
hypnosis. You're you're focusing, you're
breathing, you're entering an altered
state of consciousness,
>> right?
>> Um that's why a lot of times when you go
into an eastern healing place or a new
age healing place, they'll have certain
smells, they'll have certain music,
they'll have certain incense that is to
help you enter an altered state of
consciousness to shut down the frontal
lobe, your guard.
According to Tibetan priests, this same
word dana is translated as goyan, which
means to become familiar with oneself.
According to Buddhist and Hindu
teaching, the practice of diana
meditation is used to achieve an altered
state of consciousness they call
samadei.
Now that's I know this is information,
but listen to what the word samadei
means. It means an intense concentration
achieved through meditation at which
point a union with the divine is said to
be achieved.
>> Oh, so here comes again that idea that
you are God and you're supposed to
become even more like God, which is
exactly what Satan did.
>> So is that what that little symbol right
there is?
>> M. That's the the symbol for the word M.
>> Like when when they chant that, it
invokes the sun god.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So when people are
doing that, you know, they're doing
that, it is actually saying, I am asking
for you to empower
>> and who in all ancient culture, the sun
god, you know, in all different forms is
is a symbol of Lucifer.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, wow, dude. That's crazy.
>> And that's exactly what we just talked
about. Genesis chapter 3, Satan said,
"You will not surely die, but you will
be as gods."
>> Yep.
>> Couple of mo more slides.
This is Thomas White. He was a tenth
dawn in karate. He said karate is not
something that one does. It is something
that one becomes.
>> Mhm.
>> Karate.
>> The word karate means empty hand. M
>> and although the external though the
external mask of training the external
mask of training might be readily seen
in the lighted arena the essence of
karate do is ever the veiled presence of
being.
>> Wait a minute. He said the mask of
karate. If you have a mask that means
there has to be something behind the
mask.
>> Right? If you have a veiled presence of
being,
what presence is being veiled?
>> Something.
>> What's interesting with the little 666
on his arm? [laughter]
>> I've always, you know, that's one thing
I've always told people is when it comes
to martial arts is different than, you
know, having a gun. A gun you can put
down, you can holster it, you can set it
on the shelf. Martial arts goes with you
everywhere you go.
>> Yeah.
>> You can't put it away.
>> Yeah. It's always there.
>> It is you. It becomes you. That's that.
And Keith knows. I know. So what is this
spiritual element that is veiled? What
is this presence which the masters are
seeking to obtain?
This is Moria, the founder of Iikido.
And he's holding his hand out because
he's talking about to his students, you
have the power of the universe in your
hand. The word karate do means the way
of the empty hand. And a thought came to
my mind probably within the last two
years, maybe three years of me training.
I was like, my main style was Chinese
kung fu, but I knew karate. I knew I'd
trained in karate. And I was like, wait
a minute, why did they call it the way
of empty hand? Cuz we trained with
boans, we trained with uh nunchuckas, we
trained with, you know, staffs, we
trained with size, we trained with all
kinds of weapons. What do you mean it's
empty hand? There's no empty hand. We we
did do emptyhand, but we did all kinds
of weapons as well. And then it was like
it hit me
when when we did like you familiar with
iron palm like where you know people
would they put this energy into their
hands so that they could smack rocks or
concrete blocks and crack them. And I I
remember one of the the Burmese
instructors that I had, he would take
two fingers and he could crack a coconut
and shatter it. Coconut's harder than
the human skull,
>> but he had to put that energy into the
hand in order for this energy, which is
the same energy that the acupuncturist
is channeling. It's the same energy that
the Reiki healers are channeling. In
order to get this energy into the hand,
you have to empty your mind out of the
hand so another mind can take possession
of it.
>> To be an empty hand means
>> something else goes into that hand,
>> right? M
>> and does the fighting.
>> Wow.
>> And it's interesting in the Bible, the
hand is also the action, right? So
you're receiving something
>> and then you're acting on it.
>> Now you think, okay, why do they always
tell you to empty your mind? It means
mushin. Let go of your mind. Let go of
your identity and become one with the
universe
>> and let some something else in.
>> Let another And it's not you're not
becoming one with the universe. What
you're doing is you're opening the door
and an evil spirit is coming in and
taking the chair.
>> Yep. in your life, the driver's seat.
Gein Fukakushi said, "You may train for
a long time, but if you merely move your
hands and feet and jump up and down like
a puppet, then learning karate is not
very different from learning a dance.
You will never have reached the heart of
the matter. You will have failed to
grasp the quintessence of karate dough."
And you know what the thought that came
through my mind was? What is
quintessence? I'd never even used that
word before. I looked it up in Webster's
dictionary and they said quintessence is
the fifth and highest element in ancient
and medieval philosophy that is said to
permeate all of nature and is the
substance composing all celestial
bodies, planets,
>> right?
>> In physics, it is a hypothetical form of
dark energy, the fifth fundamental
force, the fifth element. By ancient
Greeks, it was this force which was
thought to fill the universe and hold
all things together. That's that sounds
like George Lucas Star Wars.
>> Yeah, very true.
>> That I mean that's almost verbatim.
Master or actually Grandmaster Nakiyama,
he said it is this highest stage, the
essence common with the marshall ways of
Japan that I would next explain. In
short, the Zen priest says that the mind
if placed nowhere is everywhere.
>> The concept reflects Buddhism's
abhorance of attachment and bonds. Such
antipathy is based on the concept of
what they call void. In Buddhism, the
English word void or emptiness
translates in the Japanese word coup,
which derived from its original Hindu
meaning is this that we should not be
trapped by the difference between good
and evil.
>> Oh wow.
>> That's where this this this is where the
end of this road goes. It doesn't matter
if it's yoga. It doesn't matter if it's
Buddhism. It doesn't matter if it's
martial arts. Doesn't matter if it's
acupuncture or raiki. It makes no
difference. This is the end of the road,
right?
>> This is where all of them lead.
>> So light becomes darkness and darkness
becomes light.
>> And scripture tells us, "Woe unto them
that call evil good and good evil. That
put light for darkness and darkness for
light." There's a there's a new Marvel
film called The Thunderbolts.
>> Yeah.
>> And they're like a bunch of kind of
anti-heroes.
Um, but in that film there's a character
called Sentry. He's supposed to be like
a a Marvel version of Superman.
And so there all the Thunderbolts I
think are all human and you know they
even though they have enhanced physical
powers, they can't, you know, match up
to this character strength. But he has
an alter ego. Do you know what it's
called?
>> What?
>> The void.
>> Really?
>> And it's black. It's darkness.
It's like when you when you like try to
see this character, it just looks like
>> interesting
>> emptiness, empty space, blackness. It's
like a silhouette. And he's called the
void.
>> Isn't that interesting? And also just
considering that how many other
celebrities have alter egos, you know,
that that that makes them do all kinds
of things that they normally wouldn't
do.
>> Do y'all remember that movie The Last
Samurai with Tom Cruz?
>> A little bit.
>> Okay. He described this in that film. He
was he was practicing this and they
taught him he was a warrior but they
wanted he wanted to learn how to become
like them which was invincible almost
>> and they taught him this is what you
have to do and they show him getting to
this place where his body was moving
without him telling it. This this was
the the verse in the scripture that God
used. This was like
>> this was the sword that pierced through
the darkness. This was the light. I
remember one day I was there at home. It
was actually nighttime and I was looking
through all these martial arts books and
Eastern mystical books I had in my
library and I was trying to understand
God but what about this and what about
this and all of a sudden I kept seeing
that symbol of the yin and yong and all
these books written hundreds of years
apart in all these different cultures
Japanese Buddhist Hindu daist it didn't
matter [snorts] and God just spoke as
clear as day this then is the message we
have heard of him that God is light And
in him is no darkness at all.
>> Amen.
>> Because to the to the Asian traditional
Asian mind, yin and yang is God. It's
the Dao.
>> And they say God is only made up when
you join light and darkness together.
Yep.
>> The last Grandmaster that I trained
under, I don't even like calling him
that. Um
>> his name was Dana. And I'm I'm praying
for him. I ask everybody that's
watching, pray for this man, Dana.
>> Dana was in um um Dragon Revealed. He
was the the one you were speaking about.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's our documentary uh about
Eric's life
>> about about the freedom that Christ
>> Exactly. Your testimony. So, link in the
description for whoever wants to watch
that.
>> I remember when I went to train with him
one time. I was asking him because I was
I was already a fifth dawn and I wanted
to be a sixth dawn. I wanted a seventh
dawn. And the only way to get there is
if you train in Chi. You're not going to
get promoted to a sixth dawn if you're
shutting the door. But I remember I
asked him about the the the chi because
I heard him talking with one of the
other uh black belts that was there and
he said something that that opened that
conversation up and he told me
something. He said, "Eric, this energy
that we're talking about that we learn
to channel and we learn to develop cuz
we would channel it out of trees. We'd
go out there and you know put our palms
up and absorb this energy from trees.
You feel something?"
>> Oh yeah.
>> Wow.
>> That's where the term back in the hippie
days was called tree huggers. That's
what they were doing.
>> Oh wow. Um but Mori Yishaba, the founder
of Aikido, there's pictures of him doing
that. He'd be at a tree and he'd be
holding his palms out absorbing this chi
energy. [gasps]
>> Um but he told me something. He said to
the beginners, he said, "Eric, we tell
them that chi is just simply internal
strength. It's just something that's
inside you you got to learn how to tap
into." M
>> he said to an intermediate student which
is normally like a brown belt or or
maybe even a black belt a beginning
level black belt he said we tell them
it's breath he said but to a disciple or
to a master we revealqi is spirit
>> and it was interesting to me because in
the bible the word spirit and breath in
Hebrew is often the same word
>> but I knew I was like he's not talking
about the bible he's sayingqi is spirit
it. And if anybody will send me an
email, I've got a book called the
Exposing the Cult of Keyong for what it
is. That book, which I read in like two
days online for free, was written by a
Chinese um Keong master who had also had
involvement in acupuncture, I believe,
and some other things. And God set him
free. He had no didn't know any Bible
stories, didn't know anything about
Jesus. And God sent somebody to set him
free. and he wrote this book exposing
where it all comes from. And he talked
about this.
This is a picture with me and that that
man that I trained under last, Dana. Um
the the calligraphy does not mean what
I'm I'm going to show. I just put the
calligraphy up to show an example of the
Chinese calligraphy.
I remember when I was there, I had went
to train with him. He actually he was he
was living outside Atlanta at that time
in a place called Woodstock, Georgia.
And I was driving down from outside
Johnson City, Tennessee. And whenever I
would go down, I mean, when you get to a
certain level in the martial arts, you
don't have to train with your instructor
every single day. I only have to I could
go down once every six months. He would
tell me what he wanted me to do. I'd go
back and practice it, come back and show
him. And he's like, "I don't have to to
see you every day." Mhm.
>> So, I showed up and while I was there,
we were just kind of chit cchatting
before we started training and it was a
one-on-one class and one of the young
black belts came in. He was probably in
his mid20s, maybe late 20s. And he had
this huge piece of artwork that was
wrapped up in brown paper bag. You know
how like they used to do that brown
wrapping paper. And he came in and he
said, "Cjo, see Joe, they finished it.
They finished." He was really excited.
And CJ Joe just nodded, you know,
pointed to set it down. And uh and you
know, the young man stopped because he
wanted to see it unwrapped. He wanted to
see what it looked like. And Dana looked
at him. He just did that, which means
you're dismissed. And you could just see
it, the look in the younger guy's eyes
cuz he was like, "Man, [clears throat] I
really want to see this." And um after
he left, Dana went over and he unwrapped
the the twine around it and he pulled
the paper off and there was this piece
of calligraphy. And I knew a couple I
mean like less than five. I knew what
those five calligraphies meant. I'd
never read or written in in Chinese. So
I looked at the calligraphy and it's
gorgeous. When they do those brush
strokes, I mean a good calligrapher is
beautiful art.
>> But I saw it and I I I knew this is
gorgeous. I have no idea what it says.
>> And he knew that's what I was thinking.
>> And finally he just kept looking at me
and finally I was like I said, "What
does it mean?" And he looked down at the
ground for a minute and then he looked
back up at me and looked me right in the
eye and he said, "Eric," he said, "The
easiest way to translate this in English
is it's the devil that's in the
details."
>> Wow.
This guy was a tenth dawn in two systems
of Chinese kung fu. A tenth dawn.
>> He knew what he was talking about.
>> He had been training for probably 45
years at that point. 41 to 45 years
every day.
>> And he's a Christian.
>> No.
>> No, not at all.
>> No. That was the first man I trained
under.
>> Okay.
>> No, he was not. He was raised in a
Christian home.
>> My wife and I actually
>> He's aware of Christianity. He bought
him a Bible after I walked away from the
martial arts and we got his name put on
it and I was like I I pray Lord keep
that Bible in his house.
>> But he said this. He said it's the devil
that's in the details. She is spirit. So
when we talk about channeling this
energy as an antenna, the antenna that
that little needle acts like in
acupuncture, that energy is going
through the practitioner, through the
needle into the person. That energy is
spirit. That spirit is what's causing
the results of that whatever that
healing
>> practice is supposed to be.
>> Mhm.
>> The Bible tells us in 1 Corinthians
chapter 6 and second in chapter 6 and
chapter 3. What know ye not that you are
the temple of God and that the spirit of
God dwells in you? If any man defiles
the temple of God, him will God destroy.
For our God is a consuming fire. For the
temple of God is holy, which temple you
are.
>> And what agreement has the temple of God
with idols. For you are the temple of
the living God. This is talking to you.
This is talking to each of us. You are
the temple of the living God. as God has
said, I will dwell in them and I will
walk in them and I will be your God and
you shall be my people. In Revelation,
and forgive me, I've got a typo there.
In Revelation chapter 18 and in 2
Corinthians chapter 6, it talks about
this. It says, "Wherefore come out from
among them and be ye separate, sayeth
the Lord, and touch not the unclean
thing, and I will receive you, and I
will be a father unto you, and you shall
be my sons and daughters."
>> Amen.
>> God is telling us as Christians,
>> you are the temple of the living God.
You can't combine light and darkness.
You can't blend Eastern spirituality
with Christianity. And he's telling us,
come out of her, my people.
>> Yeah. He's got a better way for us, a
better life that he wants to give
everybody. I mean, amen.
>> Th this this thing of acupuncture or
raiki or martial arts,
>> it might seem really attractive, but
it's a lie. It's a deception. You know,
it's it's you're playing with the dark
side. You're not actually helping people
or helping yourself or bettering the
world, which I believe a lot of people
who get involved with this are very
genuine and they really do have that
desire to help people.
>> I was.
>> Yeah. Exactly. But but you know, I I
just hope that when people see this that
they realize there's something there's a
big deception going on. You know, it's a
big lie from the force of darkness. And
Jesus is the true light, the true
enlightenment. And he is and I'm talking
about the biblical Jesus to be very
>> very um you know, particular. I'm
talking about the biblical Jesus, uh,
Yeshua, you know, and Yhovah, and and
talking about him that he is the savior
of mankind. He's the only one who can
give us peace.
>> Do you know what's neat, too? He can
heal every disease.
>> Yeah, it's true. He did.
>> Do you know what I found in my own life,
and I'm still experiencing this? As you
begin reading God's promises for healing
out loud and putting your name into it,
the Bible says, "Faith comes by healing,
by hearing and hearing by the word of
God." That's right.
>> Your faith grabs hold of his promise and
the healing becomes yours.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah. You know, the counterfeit is is so
close like like you're talking about a
way of life. You know, this martial arts
that they even talk about it just like
that. This is the way of the martial
artist.
>> And it's like Jesus is like, I'm the
way.
>> And it's the same way with the Eastern
healing.
>> You know what I mean? It's like the same
almost just such a subtle difference
between the two.
Just one more quick highlight. You know
the symbol of the yin and yang.
They call the dao the way.
>> Mhm.
>> It's the combination of light and
[music] darkness.
>> Mhm.
>> On the highest levels, they reveal to
you that that white section represents
heaven. The black section [music]
represents earth. The white section
represents spirit. The black section
represents flesh. It is the union of
flesh with spirit. M
>> that's what God wants for us. But Satan
is saying I'll put a different spirit in
there.
>> Well, yeah. And the unification, not
that we become gods. That's not what God
wants. But he wants to dwell in our
hearts and have a [music] relationship
with us
>> and then we become partakers of the
divine nature.
>> Yeah. He wants to restore [music] us
into his image.
>> That's right.
>> Mhm.
>> [music]
[music]